Spain's central government took dramatic
action this morning an attempt to thwart
Catalonia's move toward independence
seven and a half million people live in
the northeast region of Spain Tim Wilcox
with our partners at the BBC is in
Barcelona with what Spain's emergency
action means well it was described as
the nuclear option and many people
didn't think it would happen but the
government in Madrid has decided to
invoke article 1 5 5 now what does that
mean that's article 155 of the 1978
Constitution it's never been used before
but effectively it is imposing direct
rule on Catalunya from Madrid this is a
huge moment constitutionally for this
country it follows that referendum
deemed illegal by Madrid here on October
the 1st Madrid said what are you doing
that's illegal it's against the
Constitution and ever since then there's
been this game of cat-and-mouse between
the government in Madrid and the Catalan
Parliament here Carlos kucha mom a few
days ago
declared independence for Catalonia and
then suspended it saying he wanted
dialogue with a Madrid Madrid gave them
a deadline of eight days to revoke that
decision that has passed and now direct
rule will be imposed by Madrid the
cabinet meeting on Saturday to decide
precisely which measures they are going
to impose Jeff Tim Wilcox in Barcelona
thank you